Dave McMenamin ESPN NBA and Sutter how
are you Dave I'm doing great rich and
Chris good to be all if you guys they're
good to have you back here you guys go
way back right Chris and you and accused
2002 that's right
back in a long time ago Syracuse is Dave
McManaman here on the Rich Eisen show so
then let's let's discuss what you made
of Zions debut and what you might have
already heard from folks that you
contact and speak to you around the
league I mean just really happy the way
it turned out now it wasn't ideal for
him to be limited to that strict minutes
barrier and come out in the middle of
this incredible little run that he had
when he had you know brought the
pelicans all the way back and I took the
lead over the Spurs but his feel it from
afar to watch it on TV in New York and
to see the energy in the building to see
the smile on his face
you know everything you hear about his
ion is that he just really loves the
game of basketball and it was hurting
him to be sending out all that time
returning from that knee injury and then
he just really showed out LeBron's debut
which is the only thing we really have
to compare this thing to was 25 points
in 42 minutes and he puts up 22 and 18
minutes you know I just can't wait to
watch him grow even more and more games
under his belt this season what do you
think Jim Gentry and the pelicans plan
is for for the short and and the rest of
the league I'm invested the league
season future what do you think the plan
is here Dave David Griffin told agent
Washington Althea on the woods pod today
that you know he could tell that the
coaching staff didn't really love that
plan but he doesn't care the his job is
to make sure that the long-term health
design is intact so basically according
to Griff
the indicator was as soon as the
training staff sense that Diane was
starting to dip into playing with
fatigue they decided to pull him and you
know that's kind of tough to hear
because we're so used to watching the
sports and and it's kind of what is that
little extra that you have
in the tank when everybody's fatigued
that separates the winners from the
losers but you know at the same time I
don't think his body is where they want
to be in terms of you know this whole
idea of their retraining him in several
aspects of the physicality and so until
he gets to that level that that they
have in hope for him I think they're
gonna be super cautious Dave McMenamin
here on the Rich Eisen sure I love that
so so Griff tells woods to use the
phrase at the the shorthand here that
this is the plan I don't care if Alvin
Gentry and the coaching staff has a
problem with it and they do they would
like to press the pedal to the
williamson metal a little bit more as
what you're saying yeah I understand the
thinking about monestery I mean you know
why do you want to take your kid out who
scored 17 straight points in the fourth
quarter when you have a chance to win
and when you know you're a team that is
actually as of late been putting
yourself in position to maybe make a
playoff for so these games really matter
I think the Griffin point of view is
that as much as this game might feel
like it matters what really matters is
whatever we can do to have the most out
of my eye on over the seven years that
we have them guaranteed so outside of
this the story of the NBA season is what
would you say is what so far how the
Lakers have maybe over performed on I
understand that's a difficult word to
use when LeBron and Anthony Davis are
our teammates the the honest future give
me give me the I guess Thursday before
Super Bowl week story for the NBA season
here Dave Luca breakout has been
incredible to watch he's a truly special
player he's doing this in just a second
here in the league and there's very few
holes to his game and he's made Dallas
you can talk to yourself into thinking
that they'll be a contender this year if
they make some moves around the fringes
at the trade deadline you know because a
lot of their success this year has been
without having kristaps porzingis
consistently
with injuries Lukas that good Yanis of
course you know it looks like he'll be
the back-to-back MVP here and so you
know he's had some games along this
stretch where he's shown an outside shot
which was really the only thing that
stopped him from seeing Toronto Raptors
in the playoffs last year he you know
they snagged on him and fill up the lane
and dare did the shooting he couldn't
make job and so you know that attention
I think some of the turmoil and
potential turmoil and silly is very
interesting and and then you know other
than the Lakers playing so well the
Clippers just seemed to be a team when
they turn it on they look like the best
team in the league but a lot of times
they don't turn it on because it's the
regular season what about that Philly
turmoil let's let's pull on that string
a little bit here and how you see that
all playing out over the next several
weeks
come on the Lakers I think it was I
think he was you know LeBron or Andy
Davis in the last couple weeks talk
about how well they're playing and he
said all the pieces fit and it's just
the exact opposite and in Philadelphia
the pieces don't fit Ben Simmons is
shown out right now while Joey is not in
the lineup and when JoEllen beads in
there and and occupies the space that he
does and rightfully so he's the best big
men in the game and Simmons this game is
limited you know cuz there's not the
space on the floor for him to get into
the lane that's that's where and bead
has to be most of the time you know or
less you make him beat us and still
three-point shooter which isn't doing
his cell talents the full service they
deserved and so there's there's there's
a push and pull there and you already
had a coach in Brent brown who there
last season many believed in the playoff
series coaching for his job and I'm not
so sure his early season coaching
performance has inspired much confidence
that he will be the guy to ultimately
figured out what this personnel or if
they find another coach or they had to
you know think about moving a guy like
Ben Simmons to find a fit that works
better next to Joelle and because you
won't be
when healthy is like a top-five dominant
player in the game
so on your Mountain branch a smart guy
went to Duke he knows what he's doing he
must see this you must know this what do
you think the answer is what do you
think the move is here so you know I
think preaching patience is a good thing
those guys are still quite young
I personally if I was running the team I
don't think you have to you know make a
drastic move so you at this trade
midline I think you try to hope that you
know they are still incorporating a
major new piece like an out Warford you
recognize that you want to try to get
some shooting at the trade deadline
because like a couple years ago when
they added first underly silva marco
belinelli
that shooting is what allowed that team
to really you know finally make its mark
that they was trying to make I would do
that first if it flames out in the
playoffs then you had to ask yourself
some serious questions but you know
outside of Milwaukee I don't know
there's any other team in the East that
I would say has a better chance to make
the finals of the Sixers despite kind of
the the clunky formation that we're
talking about ESPN NBA insider Dave
McManaman here on the Rich Eisen show
from New York City you were in Radio
City Music Hall the other day when the
entire lower bowl was filled up with
folks who were paying their final
respects to David Stern I give you the
floor you heard a great piece on it what
what was it like in that building Dave
you know it was I had the full measure
of the man there were some great moments
of humor there were also some you know
tear-jerking moments
Magic Johnson getting up on the dais
without any notes speaking from the
heart
and saying that David Stern saved his
life you know he said it was my lowest
moment after he had retired prematurely
in a world that didn't really understand
what HIV and AIDS were and David sir not
only you know tried to make sure he
could use any connection he could to get
the best medical attention for Magic
Johnson
but invited him to play in the 92
all-star game as if to say listen we
don't view you as a cast-off you're
still part of our family and we want you
to know that you should feel loved and
embraced here and then Magic Johnson it
felt like by him playing in that game
and obviously one @dp it was a magical
sports moment he thinks he helped save
other people's lives because you know
the society at large became more
comfortable with the idea of trying to
understand what HIV and AIDS were rather
than just you know put a pox upon those
people and then you know you're backed
up in the former WNBA commissioner
getting up and saying that she feels
like David Stern deserves as much credit
in the women's sports movement movement
in this country as Billie Jean King does
you had you know David Stern son Eric it
was just a cut-up and talking about how
his dad liked to tell us her dirty jokes
and he told a couple dirty jokes to the
audience you know he was a guy who's
brilliant but he was a guy who you know
he was always bantering with the
presence and you know if you could make
him laugh or smirk you know you felt
good about yourself because you know
that's what's that kind of challenge
over there the intellectual challenge to
kind of have humor infused to the
day-to-day proceedings was what he was
all about so you know who said Radio
City Music Hall you know who would have
thought James Dolan end up looking like
a great guy that day he paid for the
entire thing right and you had I mean
rich I couldn't do anything but scan the
crowd as you know speaker after speaker
came up and you spot Oscar Robertson
Isaiah Thomas and Phil Walton until
Bradley and Michael Jordan and Kareem
abdul-jabbar how Ning Steve Nash Dirk
Nowitzki I mean the great showed up to
pay their respects which I think says a
lot
about you know who the guy was and what
he did for the game because again I
don't want to get too morbid here but
there are other commissioners out there
that I'm sure some of the game's greats
would not be showing up for mmm yeah I
mean again your pieces must read I mean
the Adam Silver talking about a member
of the media saying the when he got
cursed out by Stern was still one of the
greatest phone calls did he ever God I
mean the stories that you recount that
you were able to pass along it really
was really great stuff Dave I really you
know that's why I want part of the
reason why I wanted you on I appreciate
the call no you got it look we look for
our call out more man where we're
getting into the thick of it so we'll
chat soon oh there's Dave McManaman
getting out of he got out of his cab I
believe for more of the Rich Eisen show
tune - audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
for free on BR live or download the Rich
Eisen show app